feminism with the suffrage movement if
you had to fight your options in order
to vote was to fight in the front line
of combat would you give it up
during war times no nope so the question
again please okay so if
in order to vote you had to be drafted
and in the front lines not just like
cooking in the Army but it's all
basically yeah go to war would you still
want to vote no yeah
no no no no no no I'll still
hell no
[Laughter]
I'm learning to cook anyway
get me off of the battlefield
do you guys think the wage Gap exists no
it does does it does but it's only what
I don't know eight nine percent but are
you taking into account the time the
amount of time that women are out of
work and the amount of women that work
part-time the majority of men like they
they work full time and they work for a
lot longer than us so the statistics are
saying that there's a wage Gap generally
doesn't make any sense unless you
specify it down to women who are working
full-time and men who are working
full-time because otherwise the
statistics are skewed because
obviously there's going to be a gap in
the wages if a woman is working
part-time and a man is working full-time
and say a woman takes time out to go on
maternity leave or whatever like
I think that statistic is just silly
like if you look at men and women
actually in the same job like my job for
example
guy same age as me both graduates we
earn the same I don't I don't think you
ever walk into a job and the boss
decides she's gonna earn less because
she's a girl I think
maybe there might be a bit of bias when
employing someone do I want to hire say
a 28 year old who's just gotten married
versus say a 35 year old man if I was
the boss you know thinking financially I
would probably pick the man because okay
she's just got married she's 28 she's
not got much time left she's probably
gonna have kids soon you have to pay for
a mature all right yeah you have to pay
for thinking of that from an employer
perspective yeah I gotta pay for you to
not work for six months no I agree
completely yeah and that's the thing
women don't want to do the most
stressful jobs typically and I say this
from like hiring people I've had
situations where I'll offer people rules
here where they'll make like double
triple the amount like but they'd have
to recruit and recruiting is hard and
they don't typically want to do it
and it's stressful because we can't do
the show if you don't do it but women I
don't know they just don't want to do
those jobs exactly and like if you look
at jobs like for example like labor jobs
I mean I don't know a lot about this
um but you know the majority of women
aren't in labor jobs and people love to
scream oh this is inequality and you
know women aren't welcome in these
industries now be real with yourself do
you actually want to be on a
construction site and the majority of
women don't want to be there so that's
why we're not there that's actually true
you just can't so if that means there
would be a gap in the working industry
with man and woman a wage Gap how would
there be a wage Gap because if a woman
got employed in the labor job same as a
man she would still earn the same so
there wouldn't be a wage she wouldn't
earn the same because she wouldn't be
able to do the job anyway she's not
physically strong enough to do the job
and the boss will see that so he's not
going to pay someone full wage knowing
that she can't even partake the full job
anyway she's not doing the same work as
the guy anyway so it's not equal
inequality she's not capable of doing
what the man's capable it would be
really unfair to pay her the same and a
man break is every day and her get the
same money I'll be livid if my husband
come home and as a woman doing less and
he's been coming home broken and like
that's just not right yeah no fair
enough I mean I just think like
you usually hear things of people saying
like you know um I went on a podcast
recently and we were discussing
engineering and I was on there with a
girl who was talking about how she was
in engineering and she was really
successful in it like she was actually
like above the majority of men she was
in quite a high power position she she
struggled in that position obviously
because getting a group of men to listen
to you when you're in in an industry
like that is going to be quite hard
um but I just think like
women the majority of the times aren't
in those jobs because they don't want to
be like obviously physical strength is a
limitation of course but I I do believe
that in this day and age if you want to
do something you can go and give it a go
and I think
if a woman wanted to be in the labor
industry she would and could and should
go give it a go but I do agree that well
I'll be honest I'm a build fiber
engineer so I'm the one that's picking
up the Dark Side of everything and
pushing through cables and everything
bringing fiber to people's and do you
earn the same as yours yeah I do iron
exactly the same so I I want to ask a
question would you guys work in an oil
rig in Alaska for three hundred thousand
dollars a year raise your hand if you
would yeah I would I would it's all
right
purely for curiosity
an adventure
but that's what I mean if you ask a
group of guy that guys that questions
half of them are like I'm gone they're
going for the piece like to get out the
crazy households that exist now like yes
please
do you think women are more masculine
today than 50 years ago definitely 100
and have you guys ever struggled with
your femininity
[Laughter]
oh okay someone anyone who struggled
with their feminine I would say I
struggle in a sense where I have no
choice but to be masculine to fend for
myself because there isn't really any
man providing for me in that sense so
I'm forced to actually be masculine and
then you know pay for my rent the car
the everything else I have to pay for if
I had the choice I would choose to drop
that tomorrow and actually just have a
guy do all of that are men forced to be
feminine when they're single fathers
um yeah because there's no woman in the
home not necessarily they can go from a
female to a place I feel like they would
have to tap into certain feminine roles
I wouldn't say they have to be feminine
but they might have to
um do something that they wouldn't have
to do like for example if they have a
like for example I lived with my dad for
a period of time my mom was in the home
he had to tell me about which was very
awkward monthly your period yeah to have
that conversation with me whereas if a
woman was in the house right but does he
start acting like a girl like is he like
no definitely
[Laughter]
he had to step into a feminine role
right but he was still very masculine
right but I feel like
how can I speak but I think that's how
guys hear it when we when we say we have
to be masculine yeah because there's no
masculine because there's not a guy
around or we have to do masculine things
I feel like for me when I had to it was
in masculinity is when I was in a
relationship where the man wasn't
leading so I wasn't able to be feminine
he was allowing me to make this like I
don't I like making decisions but it was
a thing of where I was making all of the
decisions I thought it's fine you know
you have the last saying it was that
okay like oh you do this you do that I
was in a masculine energy because the
man wasn't operating in the masculine
energy yeah so I was basically like
struggling and fighting every single day
why are you picking feminine men do you
know well I was very young when I met
him I was 18 so I didn't know about
feminine masculinity you're young oh he
looks good or he's nice and you just go
with the flirt so I didn't know that
then it wasn't until seven years have
gone past wait okay so you didn't notice
it for seven years I noticed it but I
was like ignoring it because I was like
this is who I love I want to be with and
ignore when you're in love you're
blinded so for seven years you were
masculine masculine yeah so how did you
stop being masculine because I'd imagine
like if you do something for seven years
how do you just break that habit to be
honest with you
um still in therapy I'm still healing
and learning I haven't stopped being
masculine I'm learning how to not be
masculine so I'm single at the moment
because I've had to learn that I
basically stopped by not being that
person anymore and realizing that oh my
gosh I was operating in masculine energy
because they wasn't and it wasn't even
their fault it's just something that
they couldn't do it wasn't within them
so now I'm in a learning process okay I
don't want to be masculine anymore I
want to be feminine I want to be soft
but still I'm not a type of soft person
that just sit at home no I like to work
I like to earn but I want to be able to
be
for a man to look at me and be like this
is a woman
she's not trying to be strong or like
aggressive I don't want to be like that
but yeah so I'm still in the process of
so for the single fathers what actually
stops the guy from getting a replacement
woman
what stops him what stops him getting a
replacement woman
I mean maybe he doesn't like the modern
women today a lack of wives
um common law marriage
I mean the risks that come with marriage
not wanting to bring a bunch of women in
and out of the home knowing they might
leave
and like knowing that's hard on a child
yeah but then even if he just finds a
girlfriend to just facilitate the mother
being there so he doesn't have to be a
full-on feminine he might not want to be
introducing women to his child because
it's not easy he might think well if I
introduce this woman how long she's
going to be there for I mean women I
mean women leave 70 to 80 percent 80
percent of the time in divorce like in
marriages and so if it's a girlfriend
how long is she really going to be there
mm-hmm
I'm sure he can find a solution for that
I mean I think that's a feminine point
of view because for us it's like there's
always someone yeah but for men it's not
always I mean one in three men are
sexless they haven't had sex in the past
year or they're virgins under 30.
and and so it's not as simple as oh just
find someone
it's very very very easy to actually
find just a normal genuine female that
can actually facilitate her needs
because
I think it's extremely difficult to find
anybody in the world today like yeah
when you say like there's men that have
gone without being in a relationship for
years I'm one of those people like I've
gone years without seeing anyone because
I'm that fussy in that particular with
what I want in my life and then in terms
of like having someone around my child I
don't believe I could even consider
anyone being around my child
worthy enough to yeah I don't want
anybody around my child because I know
my partner would be upset about the fact
that there's another man around his
child so I don't think that I find that
very disrespectful unless your man has
specifically said I'm happy with that so
I couldn't disrespect his principles
there but if you really think about it
if I'm the beginning when you're
actually dating someone there's red
flags and you've got green flags and
it's very easy to actually suss out the
red flags that are there very easy
people reveal themselves in many
different ways and like I said we have
the feminist out there that's a feeling
that they want to be a feminist so it's
not easy for men to point out okay this
is what the feminists this display as I
now know what I do not want is it's very
easy I think women are very smart I can
say not just women I say men like once
you become entangled in relationships
like children marriage you that or
living with somebody I think that's when
you really get to know someone like
people change like people are pretending
to be somebody whether it's red or green
flags whatever you want to say but once
you generally get to know someone things
change people change one in four
marriages are sexless and it's usually
on the part of the women how is a guy
going to predict that
104.
it's very easy for me well no one's a
mastermind no one can actually hide
their true self right
guys
that's based to the decision that's up
to you if you wanna get married and
they'll buy a house together and like
then the woman our old man will want all
of the house like they'll lose
everything and have to start all over
again then you've got broken men and
women in society who are truly broken
children and everything I know someone
that got divorced and his ex-wife killed
his dog
how would he predict that from the
beginning she would have spent some time
I don't think that you're saying from
the beginning but you can meet someone
in the beginning and they're amazing and
that was their true self and then
they've gone through a life experience
whilst being with you and they change
people change people change monthly
daily yeah who are better Liars men or
women women definitely women women
definitely women men men are not very
good liars I don't think I think you can
always sit in their eyes I think women
maybe act better
I'm not too sure yeah women women act
better but I don't know definitely women
I think we're better at hiding things
definitely
um but seeing someone and living with
them is two different yeah 100 you never
know someone who you live with them how
much are you going to change in 40 50
years a lot yeah but if you really want
a long marriage I mean people change at
times yeah
um I agree with you some guys do ignore
red flags but I I just think when it's
their kid that's at risk it's like a lot
of guys just would rather avoid that
situation altogether
um I think that's the most likely person
that is to abuse your child
exceptionally as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible